I have to also ask you about the news
that Sammy is engaged now do you have a
message for her Jersey Shore star Ronnie
Magro is breaking his silence on
ex-girlfriend Sammi Sweetheart who
announced her engagement earlier this
year
no god bless her and I'm glad that she
found happiness yeah Ronnie invited et
to his Las Vegas home where he's raising
one-year-old daughter Ariana
yeah this is her her house and bought
this for her that was wanted her to just
have a home Ronnie gets candid about
life as a single dad everything I do now
is it doesn't affect me anymore it just
affects my child you know she has to
grow up with that you want to make sure
we're doing the right things cuz
monkey-see monkey-do yeah no and I don't
do in the same things I did that's for
sure how co-star Mike Sorrentino is
handling prison he looks good he's
getting a situation back my BDS anymore
it's definitely coming back to the
situation yeah look food give it to Big
Daddy six and the state of his on-again
off-again relationship with Gen Harley
what is the status of your relationship
today um you know right now she's always
gonna be the mother of my child
see the full interview only on e t
coming soon
[Music]